en voilà bonjour je viens de le dire mon
secours confirme qu'un sommet sur la
syrie temps cours de discussion de quels
détails
disposez-vous oui c'est lors d'un point
presse ce matin un point presse
téléphonique que le porte-parole du
kremlin dimitri peskov a tout d'abord
fait le point sur la situation dans la
région d'idleb
avant de faire part de sa préoccupation
concernant les développements de ces
derniers jours est justement à ce titre
pour les autorités russes il est
indispensable de revenir à la table des
négociations écouter en effet la
question d'organiser un autre sommet
était plusieurs fois abordé dans les
contacts bilatéraux et trilatéraux
l'éventualité d'organiser ce sommet fait
l'objet de discussions aucune décision
concrète n'a été prise
si les quatre chefs d'état considère que
cela est nécessaire nous n'excluons pas
la possibilité d'organiser une telle
rencontre
mais je souligne une fois de plus qu'il
n'y a pas encore eu de décision il ya
deux jours le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan prévenu de la possibilité
d'une offensive militaire turc imminente
dans la région d'idleb alors que ce
matin vous l'avez dit il a appelé à
entreprendre des actions concrètes afin
d'éviter une catastrophe humanitaire
dans cette même région d'idleb entre
temps les forces aériennes russes ont
appuyé l'armée syrienne dans la journée
d'hier pour contrer une attaque
terroriste à l'issue de cette opération
le ministère russe de la défense a
demandé à la turquie de cesser de
soutenir les terroristes alors on voit
bien la situation sur le terrain est
extrêmement volatil et la russie cherche
à promouvoir la voie diplomatique éviter
ainsi un conflit ouvert ce qui serait
d'après dimitri peskov
le pire des scénarios antoine merci pour
toutes ces précisions